Hey youtubers, it's Charlie. So this is gonna be a Marvel Avengers: Age of Ultron, Spider-Man vide
but because the Agent Carter finale just
happened I'm just gonna jam those videos together.
So I'm gonna start with the Spider-Man stuff first.
So the really cool news is, is that Danny
Elfman is writing music for Avengers: Age of Ultron
I know this is weird. His name appears on the poster they just released
Why is his name on the poster? Brian
Tyler scored the film
So wait for it, drum roll, obviously probably it's gonna be a Spider-Man post-credit scene to Danny Elfman
is writing Spider-Man music for. For
those who don't remember
Danny Elfman wrote the original
Spider-Man music for the to Tobey Maguire films.
They still use that score. It's the one
that everyone remembers. Brian Tyler's done
music for a lot of Marvel films but Danny
Elfman
did a lot of amazing music for the DC
Warner Brothers films.
My two favorite Danny Elfman tracks are
the Batman that Michael Keaton Batman theme
that they kept using to the animated
series and his original Spider-Man theme.
If you haven't heard them, they are on Spotify right now so you can actually listen to him for free.
There's no confirmation on whether or
not they actually found their Spider-Man,
the new actor that's gonna play
Spider-Man. But, it seems like Spider-Man,
at least, in a mask is going to appear at
the end Avengers: Age of Ultron, in like a really short scene.
There'll be multiple post-credit scenes and Spider-Man will be one of those.
It's totally unexpected, I'm really
excited, it's probably one of the best
surprises that we could have heard about.
Marvel's been releasing posters for Age of Ultron, like one a day,
counting down, so when they released the
final, they probably gonna make an announcement
about that Spider-Man or release new
trailer.
You guys can let me know how you feel
about the idea of a Spider-Man post-credit scene in Age of Ultron
I think it would give us a look at what his costume is gonna look like,
at least even if we don't see the actor's
face. While you guys think about that
careful for spoilers for  Agent Carter. I'll just go through my top five moments and give my thoughts about where season 2 is headed.
They haven't confirmed season 2 but it's
a pretty safe bet they're going to get a season 2.
So, starting with number 5: Howard Stark
returns.
I have to say that the editing on the show is great.
I always like it when characters enter a
scene finishing other characters sentences
and the thought that Howard Stark thinks
White House security sucks.
The whole point of this though is to explain
what really happened at the Battle of Finow,
what the deal with midnight oil is. Basically
what happen is is he was trying to
create Stark level know-does for
soldiers that they would have to sleep
and things went crazy. The American
general Howard Stark was working with stole research,
tested it on the Russians
and it ended up killing Fennhoff's brother and all their comrades.
It makes his revenge a little bit more
personal so I like the way they tied it back around to that
but I feel like they buried the lead a little bit.
Moving on to number 4: Fennhoff explains
to Howard Stark why he's punishing him.
So I saw a lot of parallels between
what's going on between Fennhoff
and Stark and Ultron and Tony Stark in
Avengers: Age of Ultron.
Or you could say the Avengers in general.
Fennhoff is upset that his brother died
he blames Howard Stark because in his
mind Stark doesn't think about the
consequences of his actions.
He creates weapons of mass destruction and chaos and he wants justice for that, he wants to punish him
Ultron's hatred of Tony Stark and the
Avengers in Age of Ultron
is a little bit different but it but
it's pretty close he wants to punish the
Avengers because he perceives them as
being super high on themselves
and not willing to take responsibility for the
missteps of humanity.
Obviously that's like a 150 million
dollar movie and it's a little more cats in the cradle
because Fennhoff and Howard Stark have
no familial relationship but you get the idea.
Dottie and Fennhoff's characters are really
interesting. They're nearing what's going on in their heads.
We do find out where they're coming from
psychologically, they're both really
twisted but in just like slightly
different ways.
Moving on to number 3: Fennhoff and Dottie explained.
There this really interesting difference
between Fennhoff and Dottie when they're
talking about New York City is an idea.
Fennhoff is in "Marvel of American ingenuity and what its bill, what its accomplished."
New York is a testament to the idea
that America is the land of opportunity
and you can do anything you want.
That's why he wants Howard Stark to be
responsible for destroying it.
Howard Stark represents the American ideal. He wants everyone to realize that
there's the negative side to that.
Dottie, on the other hand, seems like she
wants to tear it all down because New York,
Peggy Carter, the SSR, all represent
things that she can't have
and people that she can't be. It's like
he's trying to fill
a hole inside herself by boring a hole
in Peggy's skull.
So it's kinda like Marvel's version of 'Haters gonna hate'.
Moving on to number 2: Fennhoff brainwashes Howard Stark and he thinks that he's rescuing Captain America.
This is a lot of fun. I was like these dream
sequences that Fennhoff gets.
The logic is kinda fuzzy because
supposedly people are reliving
dreams they've had but
based on the way they explain Fennhoff
powers I suppose he could create things
inside their minds. He's basically
manipulating Howard Stark's subconscious and
conscious minds at the same time
That shield the Peggy had whenever she
walked into the scene
that's the actual shield that they use in
Avengers: Age of Ultron.
The one they had on set here was specially colored
but sometimes, whenever they filmed with the shield,
what they do is it'll be like a
toned-down color version and then they'll add all that
like silver and red and those really
bright colors in post-production.
Really fun Easter Egg two: after they filmed the first Captain America movie they
actually they gave that Captain America
shield that he had in that
to Stephen Colbert so he has like the
real deal first Captain America shield.
The I really like about this Howard
Start scene is that it humanizes him.
It's like in the first Avengers film, whenever Tony Stark flies into the portal with the warhead.
Is there a way of a toning for all the
crap that they put everyone through,
and even though we've only seen a little bit
of him, it does seem like Howard Stark isn't
quite as high on himself as Tony Stark. To be fair though,
if Howard Stark were to make himself
like an Iron Man suit and fly-around, he probably
get super high on himself too.
I think the best way to describe
Howard Stark is constantly preoccupied:
preoccupied with women
preoccupied with technology. I really
like the Trinity they have going on
between him and Peggy so
hopefully Dominic Cooper will come back
for season 2 if they get renewed.
And of course my number 1 moment: post-credit scene with Arnim Zola.
So here's what the producers explained
after the fact: Fennhoff is now
officially connected to the Winter
Soldier program
and now he's also part of HYDRA. Zola
unofficially inducts him into HYDRA.
Agent Carter always trying to loop back
with the Captain America films. Usually
it's the first Captain America film but
obviously this loops back to Winter Soldier.
I think what will happen in future seasons is just we'll see less and less Captain America stuff.
They included a lot of Captain America scenes in this series.
I always loved the integration with the
movies but I think over time what they're
gonna try and do
is make Agent Carter so it can stand
on its own so that won't need all those Avengers scenes.
As for Captain America blood you can
make as many superfish jokes as you
she poured it off the Brooklyn
Bridge so if there was any marine life down
they've gotten some extra juice.
But I'm not sure anything can live in the
East River. If you never lived in New York
the East River is where they make all
the jokes about dead bodies getting dumped.
It's like of the dirtiest bodies of
water in New York so odds are
nothing is living down there, so she
should be fine. Cut to season 2 when a
fish crawls out of the water looking
kinda like Captain America.
Let me know though what was your favorite moment. And if they do get a season two
what do you wanna see them do next? Like what story line do you wanna see them do.
Just to explain what's going on with that:
Marvel isn't the in control whether or not
it gets a season 2.
That's ABC's job. I saw a lot of people
tweeting at Marvel they're like, 'hey, we
want you to renew it' but Marvel has
nothing to do with it. They wanna season 2
just as bad as you do.
ABC is the one that has to say 'okay, yeah
we're ordering more episodes'.
If they do, there's a lot of logical jumping
off places. They did they just left a lot
of hanging threads on purpose.
Like Dottie escaped, so she's gonna come
back,
Peggy and Angie now living at Howard Stark's house,
Jarvis probably gonna come back and help them, Howard Stark probably show up every once in awhile too.
I think one thing I was kinda
disappointed by in this season that
I'm hoping we see in season two is the
creation of SHIELD.
SHIELD was actually created in 1946.
That's the year that the show takes place
so because they didn't show it's hard to
tell whether or not they're changing the time line
or if they're just fudging on how long
this was from like start to finish.
It seems like the show, like from episode
1 to episode 8
took place in like a relatively small
time-frame, like a matter of weeks.
I would expect that season 2 would pick up
within like a couple weeks or a couple months of that.
So we're still in 1946. For those who are
asking about Leviathan
so here's what I think was going on.
They kinda fudge what was going on
with that little bit.
In the comics Leviathan is a Russian
organization, it's like the Russian version of HYDRA.
On the show they made it seem like that
did exist, Fennhoff was a part of it,
part of the Russian military
organization but Fennhoff himself was
working on his own.
So be like Red Skull enacting a big
HYDRA plan and Arnim Zola going off and
doing his own thing for a little bit.
That's why they might do a little more
Leviathan stuff in season 2 but because
Arnim Zola appeared and now Fennhoff's gonna be part of HYDRA
they might start leaning into HYDRA little bit. I think it's more likely that
if Agent Carter is gonna get season 2,
season 3, they'll start to jump back and
forth more between
Agents of SHIELD. But for those who are wondering Peggy Carter
is going to be in Avengers: Age of Ultron. I don't know if it's going to be a flashback or a hallucination
because that there will be flashbacks
like Captain America will flash back to
the 1940's but
I don't know that's going to be a
fantasy sequence or if it'll be stuff
that actually did happen.
For those are asking I have no idea if Toby
Jones would be in a future season
of Agent Carter.
It means it's possible he might get cameos but it just depends on who they want to make
the main villain of the season.
What I'd really like to see them do
is go back to Vanko and do a Crimson
Dynamo storyline. That would be really awesome.
So, in related news Arrow episode 15 is
tonight, they're going to Nanda A Parbat
it's gonna be big Ra's Al Ghul storyline, so be sure to subscribe to get that video, I'll post it after the episode airs.
I haven't done my Flash bonus video yet
so I'll probably post that tomorrow just so I
have enough time to do it.
I just got some new audio gear that I'm really excited about. I'm not using it on this video but
hopefully I'll have it hooked up by the time I do my Arrow video. So hopefully this will sound nicer.
While you guys wait for Arrow tonight you can click here to catch up
and you can click here for all my Agent Carter videos.
Thank you so much watching. I'll see you guys tonight. High-fives.